SCARLETT JOHANSSON
From the very beginning, when we first
started talking about doing this
Black Widow standalone film,
there was no reason to do it
unless we could really dig deep.
KEVIN FEIGE
Black Widow had an enormous amount
of her past that has
never been explored before.
And what's fun about doing that now
is that we get to see Scarlett
as this amazing, amazing actor
and performer, with an entirely new
cast of characters in this film.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
I've, of course, over the years, thought
about what it could be, but it never
would have been able to be as
fully realized as it is now,
because I've spent over
a decade of time with this character.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
I would love to take this character in
every different direction. I think she
certainly encounters her fair share
of the Marvel universe.
JON FAVREAU
The part that appealed to me most
about her is her
dedication and just her intelligence.
She really helped design the costume,
helped to flesh out the character.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
To be a part of this is pretty exciting.
I didn't know how
the fans would respond.
I think that there's so much to explore
with Black Widow. Her past is something
that's always been shrouded in mystery.
STEVE ROGERS
You know it's kind of hard to trust
trust someone when you
don't know who that someone really is.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
Yeah.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
Really the most important aspect of my job
is to keep a
sort of steady evolution.
She has a greater calling.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
The last five years, I've been trying to
do one thing:
Get to right here.
That's all it's been about,
bringing everybody back.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
This character who has searched her
whole life for a purpose,
actually finds her purpose.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
It's okay.
JOE RUSSO
It's the single most heroic moment
in the history of the Marvel universe.
KEVIN FEIGE
You know, the hope was always to be able
to do much more with Black Widow.
And with each appearance and with
each interaction
growing and evolving her,
all, frankly, building to
her standalone movie now.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
We had the opportunity in this for
some sort of healing.
And I think you really feel that.
KEVIN FEIGE
The way Scarlett portrays this hero
in this movie is bigger and better
than anything you've seen her do
in any of the Marvel movies.
SCARLETT JOHANSSON
It's gonna let people see
who Natasha really is.
NATASHA ROMANOFF
I've lived a lot of lives.